hace un par de vídeos aprendimos que una
función que quema para el conjunto x al
conjunto y es invertible que es
invertible invertible sí solo así que lo
escribimos como sí verdad sí solo si
para cada elemento en nuestro dominio es
decir para cada g minúscula que se
encuentra en el conjunto mayúscula
existe existe y esta es la parte central
un único hilo por eso lo pongo con
mayúsculas un único elemento en nuestro
dominio tal que tal que satisface esta
ecuación fx es igual a ye verdad
entonces esto este este digamos
enunciado si quieren lo podemos ver
nuevamente con nuestros diagramas
digamos que tengo aquí el conjunto x que
tengo aquí el conjunto y entonces
estamos pensando en una función f que me
asigna puntos de x
a puntos de mi conjunto y ok repasemos
que realmente la invertibilidad me dice
que que yo puedo encontrar una función
que de hecho denota como escala menos
uno y que le llamamos la inversa de f
que existe una única función inversa que
al que después de mapear digamos este
elemento x a este elemento y con la
función inversa me regresa a mi elemento
original verdad entonces
aquí realmente lo que tenemos es que
esta función f me está mandando
elementos de x a puntos en verdad por
ejemplo podríamos pensar en este x 0
digamos este puntito x0 que me lo manda
a de verdad que es
efe x 0 entonces lo que me dice este
enunciado es que si considero y sólo voy
a poder encontrar un hecho primero me
dice que voy a encontrar un x0 o un
punto que al aplicarle la función
medalla pero me dice todavía más que no
puede pasar que yo tenga por ejemplo
aquí otro punto que al aplicarle la
función me vuelva a dar también este
punto y esto esto de aquí no sería
invertible verdad esto de aquí no sería
invertible y también no puede pasar que
tenga un punto aquí y que nadie sea
mapeado a este punto de acá verdad
entonces si si si esto si esto de aquí
ocurriera entonces si estoy aquí
ocurriera nadie es mapeado a este punto
digamos mapeado a ese punto entonces
nuestra función tampoco es invertible
deben cumplirse
ambas cosas que tanto la función sólo
tenga una única solución pero además que
todos para para todos los puntos que se
encuentren en el condominio sí pueda yo
encontrar un punto que sea mapeado a
cada uno de ellos ok entonces eso es lo
que nos dice la de la el resultado que
obtuvimos hace dos vídeos de
invertibilidad y en realidad hago este
vídeo para reescribir este enunciado en
el vocabulario que teníamos en el vídeo
pasado verdad porque porque el hecho de
que para cualquier punto yo tenga otro
aquí que va a llegar a éste a través de
nuestra función f eso quiere decir que
todo y es la imagen de x y eso significa
que es u proyectiva o que jeff es su
proyectiva
efe su project iba pero no basta verdad
no va hasta que pese a su project iba
porque podríamos tener este caso que dos
elementos después de aplicarle efe vayan
a dar al mismo punto ok entonces no
basta con que sea su project iba sino
también hay que pedirle que f sea
inyectaba para que sólo tengamos una
solución o también ya sabemos que su
project iba a veces le podemos decir
sobre y que alas inyectaba sabes les
podemos decir uno a uno es lo mismo que
uno a uno
muy bien entonces realmente este
enunciado que tenemos aquí arriba en
términos de las palabras del vídeo
anterior lo podemos expresar como si
tenemos
efe una función que va del conjunto x al
conjunto y esta función es invertible es
invertible si y sólo si si y sólo si y
sólo si ese debe cumplir dos cosas efe
es su proyectiva su proyectiva y también
debe cumplir que es inyectaba efe su
proyectiva e inyectaba nuevamente su
proyectiva es que todos los puntos en
que sean digamos la imagen o sean mateos
de algún otro punto en x y que se
inyectaba quiere decir que no hay dos
que van a dar al mismo punto en que al
aplicarles la función es verdad también
podría haber escrito este enunciado como
que es invertible sí sólo si efe
sobre y también es 1 a 1
a uno son dos formas iguales de decirle
a los mismos conceptos y estos son en
realidad formas muy elegantes de decir
que para cada elemento en el condominio
y para cada elemento en mi co dominio y
existe un único x un único x que se
encuentra en mi dominio es decir para
cada y solo voy a poder encontrar un
único x en el dominio ok que es más que
es mapeado allí por por mi función
efe que no hay más de una o que no no
hay más de un elemento en x que vaya a
dar allí y que además todo proviene de
un elemento en x